[Musique]
laura est auxiliaire de vie
elle rend visite à rené paralysé du côté
gauche par plusieurs avc son état
nécessite chaque jour l'intervention de
plusieurs personnes attendent matin qu'
elles viennent on atteint c'est un petit
peu de soleil car et je vais continuer
région vous voyez quoi mais c'est
vraiment important pour nous d'avoir ces
aides l'aura aidé rené dont les gestes
du quotidien
mais elles l'accompagnent aussi
psychologiquement ce sont des personnes
qui quelquefois ne vois personne
et je pense que c'est aussi à nous
d'apporter un petit peu de bonheur après
un petit peu de joie de vivre dans leur
quotidien des moments de complicité et
de soins qui permettent de soulager son
épouse
ça me permet de partir plus tranquille
étant donné que ce sont là et très
souvent le kiné vient l'après midi donc
ça me ça me permet de jusqu'à 4 heures
d'être libérée du souci quelque chose un
métier essentiel nécessitant des
compétences polyvalentes pourtant
rémunérés au smic en première ligne
pendant la crise elles n'ont reçu qu'une
prime dérisoire et lors du secure de la
santé leurs salaires n'ont pas été
revalorisés par le gouvernement ça
demande si ça va vraiment arriver en
fait s'ils vont enfin considérer notre
métier à sa juste valeur
on sent invisible et puis qu'ils
comprennent pas notre métier qui
comprennent pas qu'on est utile pour la
société fait partie des soignants quand
faut aller au front quand faut aller
veut faire garder nos enfants à l'école
pour aller travailler
mais quand on est sur les prix mais tout
ça sur la revalorisation du strahl rpp
personne pour se faire entendre
les auxiliaires de vie ont formé un
collectif elles attendent du concret et
non pas juste des annonces de la part du
gouvernement
de france